LaGuardia?
Today I'm traveling from
New York to Chicago
on... this plane.
It's an Airbus A319.
And I just so happened to have
the blueprints or
Aircraft Characteristics, Airport and
Maintenance Planning documents...
in my possession.
As you can see here: economy class
which is where I'll be sitting,
has a seat pitch between 28
and 30 inches.
Seat pitch is the fancy term used
to describe the distance
between where your seat begins
and the seat in front of you ends.
It's also colloquially known as
legroom, for obvious reasons.
Normally there's not enough.
There’s actually an appropriate amount of space.
Every time it’s like riding
with seats at the knees.
It could be better.
Airplane seats weren't always
designed this way.
So why have they changed?
And how much legroom have we lost
in the process?
I'm going to try and find out.
I'm 5’9” (175 cm)
which according to Google,
is precisely average.
When I'm sitting down
in an upright position
My buttock-to-knee length...
which, before you harass me
in the comments
is the official measurements
that the FAA use in its testing
ends up being about 20 inches.
And when I got on this plane...
I ended up being fairly comfortable
because I have room between my knee
and the seat in front of me.
What’s that look like?
Five, six inches?
Yeah... thereabouts.
That lovely voice
that you just heard
is my new Australian friend:
Chris.
G’day mate, y’know?
He and Brian, the two sweetest guys
in the world
who I had the privilege of
sitting next to
did not have the same spacious feeling
that I did.
There's not enough room for me
because I'm a bit around six foot.
Bit over six foot.
And it’s hard for me to fit.
I'm not that big of a guy.
I'm 5’10”.
It's pretty, pretty crowded back here.
And that might be because
we have different
buttock-to-knee ratios.
Like the space between Brian's knee
and the chair in front of him
was just...
About three inches there.
And Chris’s was...
I can’t out a knife in there!
I don’t need to measure.
When I watch movies that...
take place in 50s, 60s, 70s...
everything seems so much more
spacious and luxurious.
And it's true.
Take the DC-3
Which American Airlines began using in 1936.
AA’s president at the time,
C.R. Smith
called it “The first airplane in the world
that can make money just by
hauling passengers.”
And it was used for decades.
It seated 28 people.
And according to this 1957
Quebecair diagram
it had a luxurious seat pitch
of 39 inches...
which is like ten more inches
than I had on my plane to Chicago.
In the late 60s,
Boeing’s 737 took over.
And it became one of the most
well-known and successful
aircrafts of all time.
Iterations on the plane are still used regularly today.
These 2005 737 layout documents
show that economy seats
got anywhere from 30 to 34 inches
in seat pitch.
Today, the biggest competitor to the 737
is the Airbus A320...
which I flew on my way home
rom Chicago to NYC.
It's about twice as long as the DC-3
and can fit about 180 passengers.
And like most planes today...
seat pitch varies
within the aircraft.
On the lowest end for economy...
it hovers around 28 to 29 inches.
But there are different tiers.
Like on my flight back
from Chicago to New York
we paid about $30 extra for a
premium economy seat.
For research purposes only.
I took absolutely no pleasure in this.
The people I sat next to
weren't as chatty
as they were on the way to Chicago.
-Good luck.
-Bye!
Miss you, Chris.
But I had way more legroom.
Not only was I in Economy Plus
but I also ended up in the
notoriously spacious exit row.
While, yes, I do get extra legroom.
I also have a ton of
extra responsibility
in case this plane goes down.
But anyways
instead of just six inches
between the seat in front of me
and my knee
I now had 14.
And it was luxurious.
As if Vox had sprung for
first class for me
it would have cost $100 more
than Economy Plus.
But these schematics show
that I would have gotten
39 inches of legroom...
the same as the seats on the DC-3
from back in the day.
But instead...
I was here in
premium economy.
As I sat there with
no TV in front of me...
I began to think about
the economics of comfort.
Way back in the day
they didn't charge different prices
based on whether you had a bulkhead seat
or a window or an aisle seat.
That's Nicholas Rupp.
He coauthored this 2022 paper
that examined
in-flight amenities by carriers provided
by the US airlines.
In the past
everything would be bundled together
in your ticket price.
You'd get a carry-on,
a bag...
you usually got to
choose your seats.
But in the early 2000s
because of rising fuel costs and
a slew of difficult world events
events that made people
less inclined to travel...
airliners started to unbundle
all of those things...
seemingly starting with baggage fees
and eventually
leading to charging customers more
for seat selection.
Airlines have done a good job
at figuring out
what consumers prefer
and then being able
to extract
additional payment out of consumers.
Over the years, these extras
have added up.
JetBlue and Spirit, for example...
have increased their
overall revenues
by several percentage points
through these fees alone...
and this has forced customers to decide
with their dollar what they want.
I would never pay for more legroom.
I'm just inherently going to try to buy
the cheapest flight.
I'm not going to like buy like a nicer seat
just for like leg room.
If it weren’t so much more
I'd be willing to do that.
I feel like people that are taller
should get priority seating.
It's not their choice to be tall.
Flying isn't cheap.
But if you zoom out and take a look
at the Bureau of Transportation's
historical statistics...
and adjust for inflation, you can see that
compared to 1993...
domestic flights have actually
gotten less expensive.
Nick tells me that this is in part
because of unbundling.
And even most recently
it's due to innovations
like being able to have thinner seats.
Yeah, that means changing
the design of the seats
to literally take out padding and depth
from your seat back.
For many airlines,
this space saving meant
that they were able to add
an extra row of seats.
But most seats got an inch closer together.
For my experience, the seats were
pretty comfortable though.
I think we will not go back in time
where they had one price for
wherever you sat in coach.
I believe what we're going to see
is continue segmentation
in the market
offering a variety different
classes of products...
and then allow the consumer
to self-select.
[PA system chimes]
As I disembarked from the plane
I thought about the seats
that I had been in...
and all the people in the seats
around me.
And everyone I spoke to earlier that day.
Like this one guy...
if there could be a standard
that was less cramped...
I'd be thrilled.
In 2018, Congress sought
a standard like this
by introducing
the FAA Reauthorization Act...
which in Section 577 called for
minimum dimensions for passenger seats...
including seat pitch
as they are necessary for safety purposes.
The bill was signed into law
on October 5th, 2018
but as of 2023, there are still
no regulations
in part thanks to a March court decision
that decided
there wasn't enough clear
and indisputable evidence
that small seats materially
slow the exit of passengers
in an emergency.
Some, like Senator Tammy Duckworth
think that the evacuation studies
need to be redone
to include people with disabilities
or increased risk of injury...
to more accurately reflect
a real world evacuation.
But safety and comfort aren't
necessarily intertwined.
Comfort wasn't considered in the last study
and the word doesn't show up at all
in section 577.
For now, seat pitch
is still up to airlines...
and comfort still comes at a cost.
Once on my honeymoon,
I got upgraded to first class...
so it was quite nice.
You can enjoy that
but I'm not willing to pay that
on a regular basis.
On both my flights
I was lucky enough to not have
anybody I sat behind
recline their seats...
even though that's not necessarily
impacting legroom...
it definitely makes me feel
more claustrophobic.
What about you?
Are you pro- or anti-plane seat reclining?
Let us know in the comments below.